[Music]
so obviously I'm ready player one it was
all about testing the characters
knowledge of James Halliday but today
I'm going to be testing your Steven
Spielberg movie knowledge I have five
questions for you guys if you know the
answer right away you can shout it out
or I have multiple choice to make it a
little bit easier for you okay perfect I
can't fail this pressure
now you can phone home to Spielberg on
one of the answers in the middle okay
first one Reese's Pieces became iconic
in et but it wasn't the first candy that
they originally wanted to use what candy
that they originally want to feature in
et wow this is like behind this okay so
we have gumballs M&Ms peanut M&Ms or
bottle caps M&M I'm gonna go with
gumballs because the idea of et shooting
on gum said no and so we went to Reese's
Pieces no yes oh yeah I want to go with
M&Ms very nice Oh nicely done Reese's
Pieces were made iconic because they
were featured hold your card up there
hold it up eighteen yes they were made
iconic because they were featured in et
but that was not the original candy that
mrs. nice what type of dinosaur spit
poison and Dennis Nedry face in Jurassic
Park older
[Music]
that in the car yeah
oh man I don't know I don't know what
type of it I remember like the head like
you'd like blast these things I but I
cannot remember like what the dinosaurs
called was it a Dilla sorceress a
Stegosaurus an Allosaurus or a
velociraptor first one yeah but it's
call is pronounced a Dilophosaurus oh
I'm going to first one nicely done nice
tie Tyrannosaurus Rex no it was what was
the villain in Spielberg's film duel
tell me in Japanese oh this was in the
documentary I think it's a truck
was it a Jeep a tanker truck a tow truck
or a car carrier so I know what you're
gonna be watching tonight both you
that's how homework see would you like
to do the honors it's a truck
it's a tanker truck nice you are killing
it thank god this is nobody seen him
here well it was the dude with the truck
and also those snakes were very
formidable what was the name of quits
boat in Jaws we need a bigger boat so
that six out of six dolphin Orca or pork
or pork yes you are crushing this year
by far doing the best if you freeze
frame the Well of Souls scene and
Raiders of the Lost Ark I'll do that
there is a golden pillar with an
engraving of what character or
characters on it what the options yes
okay Elliot and ET Jaws at Aaron asaurus
rex or r2d2 and c3po oh there's so hard
it's hard to do - that's right right I'm
gonna go with the rt3 PC vo5 out of
knives and that was just by using you
know for elimination
Jack this is a trick question it's real
it is real is it well then it's gotta be
Elliot and they take it is III Pio and
r2d2 skills I got that's every
the black lesbian got all five right
please keep this in all ET I will let's
do it I'll retweet it if you put it out
Victor cliff oh you guys did pretty well
how did you think they did great great
based on the fact they haven't seen dual
yet and they the only thing they didn't
six like the only movie of yours you
know but there's been a lot of but I've
you know give them a lot of homage as to
Star Wars
you know there's r2d2 as in Close
Encounters and these are the mothership
and then and then George Lucas and then
Yoda is in et so then you must have
already loved a ready player one because
you've been leaving Easter eggs for fans
my whole career in movies and finally
they get a chance to dump the mother
lode of Easter eggs into one story
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]